he might feel how exhausted you are from
work or taking care of the kids and he
might be all right love needs to happen
his masculine gift would be to create
structure for love to happen
so he might say baby here's a glass of
wine
i drew you a bath go take a bath and
then meet me in the bedroom
in an hour more often than not when i
say that to women they'll be like
yeah that would actually feel pretty
good so now you're in the bath and
you're preparing right and so you're
gonna have to like
find your body like come out of maybe
having to be in your head all day
like oh like oh yeah it actually feels
good to have my body
like it feels good i like my skin i like
my i like the bath i
life feels pleasurable it feels good and
i love my
husband and i love that he is creating
structure and you find like you said you
you take five minutes to to connect to
the yearning in your heart
and the pleasure in your body and then
your gift to him
would be to bring that to him i believe
that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the show
is john weinland he is a teacher and
speaker
in the area of embodiment and
intimacy yep i said intimacy
it's such a topic that you know we don't
really talk about
today we didn't follow those rules and
we opened up about this topic that
we could all do a better job of being
more open and vulnerable about and
communicate
communicating better about and we just
dove overly deep into the topic of sex
so i hope you learned as much as i did
enjoy the show thank you so much john
for for doing this interview
as i said when you came on i'm like i
have so many questions there's not
enough time in the day for that
um your work is so fascinating the
masculine feminine
sex which is such a like you know
off-limits
untouched topic and you speak about it
with such
comfort like it's just it's just like
saying hello to somebody it sounds like
and it's just really really
um exciting uh because
i love to learn and so i can't wait to
ask you questions about all of this as
it's all fascinating
espec even the masculine feminine which
is something you know i've dealt with in
my life so
but what i want to know first before we
jump in is um first just like
i just kind of want to hear about where
you came from where'd you grow up what
was your family like
uh let's see so i'm a i'm a born and
raised angelino
born in pasadena lived here pretty much
all my life
i um you know my dad uh like a lot of
guys in my generation my dad split when
i was young
and so i was raised by all women so i
had my mother
my two sisters my two stepsisters my
aunt my great
i mean it was just i was the only guy
and so
i did not learn um
first of all i didn't learn how a man
operates in the world
um because my father was gone and my
grandfathers died so i didn't learn that
stuff
until i was much older and when i was
i don't know late 20s i met a group of
guys i got interest i got interested in
men's groups
and i and i met a group of guys that
really
taught me everything that i learned
everything i needed to know about being
a man
and i had a daughter and my daughter
lived 21 years she's beautiful soul but
she had cystic fibrosis so she died
but those guys um and claire was a very
beautiful
person i don't know whether you know
claire's story but she was a really
incredible
person and so you know so i've lived in
incredi
it's like an incredible life and i've
been working in men's groups now for
about 20 years teaching men's work and
teaching
um spiritual intimacy and yogic
sexuality which is part of what you were
talking about
and it usually trips people up because
i'm i'm pretty much a
regular dude right i surf i you know i i
you wouldn't look at me and go yogic
sexuality
so you know i like that i like that i
can kind of pass off
you know myself as being a pretty normal
bloke
uh but i love what i did conversations
you just kind of slip it in to see what
someone's coming
yeah yeah or keep it on the surface
yeah yeah on planes and things like that
what do you do for a living oh well
i teach people about sex and
spirituality
um so yeah you know it's
so i just i've had just the most
incredible life i'm very i love my job
and i love what i do and i love to have
conversations like this so
you know my sincere hope is that i can
be helpful to you and
anybody who listens to us what was it
that and you already are um what was it
that
drew you to men's groups well i think it
was
just not having men in my life like not
having a
father figure right and you know i come
from a long line of
hard drinking irish alcoholics so you
know so
my grandfathers were gone pretty early
and my
um yeah are you irish too i i i is
yeah dempsey is my you know my fam right
so
um so yeah i just had no
like stable men in my life and
all women and and i i i didn't know
how to do relationships like i didn't
like what does a man do
other than like make some money and
provide
you know fatherhood and some sperm and
like you know what what does a man do
in this realm of relationship and
and i learned pretty early on that i was
gonna have a really
horrible um experience with the feminine
if i didn't learn how to show up as a
man
so i found a guy that i i thought was
well this guy like he knows what he's
talking about and he said hey
i do a men's group and we meet every day
sometimes we met every day for a while
but
this has gone on now for 25 years um in
fact
i was on with them right before i
you know got the text um that i was
supposed to meet with you
so so yeah i've just it's just been such
a big part of my life to
to have men's groups and i'm a huge like
the work that i do
is to train guys to lead men's groups
because i think it's such a big
structure that's needed for men today
why is that
what do you what what is the yeah that
men's groups are are really
yeah that's a good that's a good
question i think
what what we've what we're missing this
century and last century really
are the the initiation rituals that took
boys into manhood right and they used
well i mean from from i mean you were
raised your men your father used to
teach you what it was like to be a man
like 100 years ago 200 years ago living
on the prairie living in the plains
hunting for your own
food okay like all of those things you
know you would learn from your father or
you'd learn from a group of men who were
elders in a community
and once we moved into the industrial
age
right that those communities got broken
up
right and so starting at the end of the
19th century like the
the the initiation rituals even if in
indigenous
you know like if you look at native
americans right there's there's a ritual
that would take a boy
into manhood usually involved facing
death in some way
um it usually involved like hanging from
a tree or getting bit by ants oh yeah
this stuff's all real
but for boys in the boys in the us
and in the west it was more about your
dad teaching you how to be
a man like this is how you hunt this is
how you take care of a
family and this is how you make money
and here's what you do with money and
here's how you're a husband and
and those things have been over the
course of the last 50 years pretty much
removed very very few
fathers do that at least i mean there's
some
but for the most part you've got two
generations of men
three generations of men now that have
grown up fatherless
so what does what was it that
that those activities and those
lessons taught you that made you
more of a man right right um
well there's a certain capacity to um i
mean
there's there's two pieces in particular
that are
about initiation one is to
be able to stay open like literally
feel open and not collapse in the face
of discomfort like your heart
your heart your body your awareness
right
literally to train if you were if i was
training as a martial artist
let's say in the in the east japan or
china
one of the things they trained me as a
young boy is they trained me how to be
in uncomfortable positions and stay
completely aware
stay completely focused right i mean
you're an athlete so you know right to
have that
that skill is a nervous system training
is a nervous system training and that
nervous system training was actually
ritualized
in most societies and and so men's work
nowadays is really about teaching men
kind you know
after their puberty obviously but
teaching men how to be
in uncomfortable situations and stay
open
so for example example
um a fight with your spouse
[Music]
right instead of collapsing you train
your nervous system to stay open
or work stress or what we're dealing
with now for example right all of these
things
are pressures stresses that
men men will if they don't have the
capacity to open if they were never
trained or never trained themselves
they will either numb you know read it
read it read it read it right or
or they will collapse into some kind of
numbing
experience so good men's works that's
the first thing is to train your nervous
system and the second piece is to face
death in some way
yeah and for many for many kids this was
about hunting
like literally hunting was part of
facing death like you killed something
through the 19th century again until the
industrial age that's what we did
so it's only like a hundred years or so
and in the last
50 years that's completely gone unless
your dad hunts and takes you out but
that's pretty rare
especially here in california
so facing death in some way maybe could
be an ego death
you know it could be like a death where
you like literally reveal yourself in
front of your community and they hold
you
maybe the hardest thing of all what's
that maybe the hardest one of all
yeah yeah yeah so so yeah and that's
what i think men or
men are missing and that's one of the
reasons why
men kind of come to me is is they feel
like hey there's something
in this road to masculine
maturity or spiritual development or
emotional development that i missed
um you know more men raised by single
mothers
god bless them than than ever more men
you know more families divorced than
ever and so we're at this trend is
and it leads uh because i know this will
be part of what we talk about it leads
to problems when
when you get married when you come
together and you want to
start a family of your own what about
from
the female side of things and how has
that evolved
over the last 100 years and then maybe
at the end of that
how does that collide or coincide with
the way that the man has not been
as you described you know not fully
integrated
into manhood through these activities
and through these challenges
right right well i think if there's
something similar
for women that they've experienced which
is
whereas they learned about their
feminine
right they learned about their feminine
which is the part of them
that is intuitive and flows and
so if we let me define this just so i
don't
you know trip anybody up so the feminine
in all of us
in men and women or however somebody
identifies
is uh the part of us that longs for more
the part of us that wants life the part
of us that likes color the part of us
that you know that wants
food and children and puppies and
parties and
very like more there's kind of a
moreness to the feminine
and the masculine in all of us is the
part of us that wants to take the
experience of life
and focus it into something
very sharp and directed and clear right
and and really like a race car driver
right perfect example of having to use a
masculine capacity
to right or a golfer or and and
not that those women aren't feminine or
in their essence but they had to develop
a masculine capacity
so the masculine in all of us is our
capacity
to to literally take all of existence
and
hone it into a goal or a
creation and so the other piece of the
masculine
is that the masculine craves last
less less yeah whereas the feminine once
more
if you ask any guy like what he's
looking for in his relationship or his
home life
mm-hmm more often than not it'll be
something around peace
mm-hmm or lessons like can we just get
along
or can we just have peace or can
everything just be cool or
almost any guy that well
that that's not what the feminist the
feminist saying can we have more love
and have more connection and have more
this and right and so in us
these two pieces which are both totally
natural and totally normal
um the more identified with the moreness
that a human being is like wanting more
and loving more and
craving more the more feminine
identified they are
and it can change moment to moment
different periods of their life
where they're you know whether they're
you know mothers for example or however
that happens
um and the more identified with just
wanting to
like having a sharp goal
is one thing the only thing less than
one thing like putting it over the goal
right is what you know you know over the
goal line is one thing it's one goal
get it over the goal line the only thing
less than one thing is no thing
like just nothing so the masculine in
all of us is the part of us that wants
total peace that wants to relax into
nothingness and if you think about if
you zoom out and you think about the
universe this is how the universe is
created
there's energy and then there's space
there's nothingness so if we went down
to the to the essence of an atom
there would be the energy of the of the
corks and everything moving and then
there'd be this space this empty space
in between
and so the universe is literally made up
of emptiness
and energy so are we
and so when you bring those things
together you have i mean in the
relational world you have
sexual polarity so when one partner
animates the part of them that is
feminine wanting more
flow love and one animates the part that
is
depth and consciousness and nothing
and they come together there's an arc of
sexual energy that gets created
and that's the essence of sexual yoga
so to your question what what does that
make sense
thus far yeah i mean it yes it does and
and within all of the things that you
were saying i can also
and tell me if i'm wrong but there also
feels like there's duality within each
one
like if a woman wants more like it seems
like
if that's the feminine but then you go
get it
that's masculine right it's a lot more
like
constant contrast right so finding the
balance is like
oh right well and and the difference is
is that
and this is part of the your original
question what's changed for women
so what's changed for women same thing
where there's not as much
rural sort of feminizing like
celebration of
the feminine for young for young girls
right there's less of that or
if there is it's it's also been
it's feminism in the 70s 60s and 70s
actually told women hey it's time to
to compete with men to you know you
should be in the same
arena as men right you you've learned
this obviously
and and so we're gonna go do this and
it's great and it
probably hundreds of years too late
however
that same skill set of learning to drive
and compete and go get it
actually is antithetical in the area of
polarity and relationship and this is
where women
and men are having this disconnect so
the more a woman
is telling is directional with her
masculine partner assuming her partner's
masculine
the less space he has to be directional
so he she's now in the masculine and
he's now following
which is fine except there's not
it tends to impact their sexual
chemistry
it tends to mess up their chemistry
and so women who are completely capable
of leading
in so many or every area of their life
are will often use the
skill sets they've learned to deal with
the
issues of relationship the issues of not
getting met or not being seen or not
feeling safe
and that actually tends to make things
worse and so we have this
now we're in this space a relationship
where um
where women are often better men than
men
women are often better equipped in the
masculine
than men who've been raised without men
and so
they're they lead better they direct
better and
even though this is often really good in
life
parenthood that kind of thing it doesn't
necessarily work in the
sexual realm um
we're going to get there yeah yeah it's
like the for sure
most important thing that i want to talk
about but before we get there
because i feel like there's like a base
to it there's got to be
an understanding within yourself and
then within the relationship
and then you can enter into how that
looks in intimacy
so the curiosity i have is first
stepping back and going
okay how can i i mean i'll use myself
as an example because for sure i think
that
in my life i have had to cultivate so
much masculinity
um and so one of the things that i've
been working on
over the last like year or so really
intensely is to try and soften and try
and
be more feminine and be less like cold
directional
go do this making decisions like all
things that i'm very good at but i
practiced it for 25 years so
um you know i find myself stepping in
stepping away from racing and being
retired and
you know in a relationship where my
partner is very masculine
and i can see what you're saying now
about the masculine being like
less because he's very like it's very
relaxed and so
there almost appears to be a femininity
to it because it's almost like a
passiveness
right but he's i'm understanding now
just so masculine that my masculinity
like we just like
there's clashing yeah so how can
how can i how could one i'm just
basically i just want people to know
that
like this is i mean this is normal this
is
normal in modern relationships because
so many women are like you
incredibly successful incredibly like
accomplished in the world
and and yet your essence is feminine
you'd probably
prefer to be ravished and led
and taken care of and cherished well
that just means you have a feminine
essence
um sexually at least right and
relationally so
yeah it's so what what i try to teach
people is that yes
we both have both and so the first step
is to get aware
of what area needs to be strengthened
kind of like what you talked about like
okay like i've spent all this time
working
to be directional and goal centered and
meticulous like you have to probably i
mean i don't know anything about
driving race cars but i imagine the
level of meticulousness
is off the charts right and
so you go from that to to being
the best way to describe just the
essence of feminine practice is
uh the embodiment of pleasure and love
right so the questions yeah so
pleasure so the more that you can
conduct
so if if we think about masculinity and
femininity as
transmissions right like so as a
transmission
of femininity i could do this too in my
body i could start to move in a way
where love starts to flow through my
fingers or
flow through my eyes or my hips and i
could literally
transmit love and energy
the more i'm doing that the more
feminine
i'm the more femininity i'm transmitting
and by transmitting you mean embodying
that feeling so that
it's literally coming out of your body
as an energetic field
exactly people feel like so you people
feel like uh who's a great example of
beyonce right if you ever say if you saw
beyonce coachella piece where she did
all these
all these costumes and all you know it's
the essence of what people are paying
for
what they're really wanting is the it's
it's the feminine
fully embodied fully expressed in song
and dance and movement in more right
this is why she got paid what she got
paid
um there's so
so the more that i'm the more that i'm
connected to pleasure
and love the more i am connected to the
feminine the universal feminine
the more i'm connected to depth and sort
of the infinite
consciousness the more i'm connected to
the masculine
yeah the more you can feel that through
me the more i'm perceived as masculine
so i'll let me give a little bit let me
give a little bit i'll step back
yeah let me step back so uh
the masculine in all of us is the part
of us that has
has never changed so you can feel the
part of you
danica now and danica f5
and there's a sameness right it's the
same you even though your cells have
changed
your habits have changed everything's
changed your whole life has happened
since then
and and same with me the part of me that
is
unchanging and infinite right some
people would call it god some people you
know whatever
people have different words for it so
there's the
the part of me that's unchanging and
infinite that is our masculine
the part of me that's always changing
the part of the moment that's always
changing
is the feminine
so in any moment or let's say let's stay
with people
in in you there's a part of you that's
unchanging and totally still
and totally infinite like you can feel
that
[Music]
and yet there's everything that's moving
like you're hearing my voice
you're hearing my you're feeling the
sensation in your body
there's things going on in the room
around you
that is the essence of a masculine
energy and a feminine energy
now the more that you're transmitting
that
infinite stillness through your body
the more you will be perceived and felt
by people around you as masculine
does that make sense is that a little
clearer so if you walked into a room
it doesn't matter woman it doesn't
matter like you could walk into a room
like still and present and walk into the
room like
very solid like like a tree
and people would feel your masculinity
and your essence then because to me no
well they're both so so whichever you
relate to
more is your essence wherever feels like
home to you
yeah so some people have like if if you
feel
i mean this we could go down the rabbit
hole here but some people will have
feminine minds
and masculine minds some people could
have feminine emotional bodies or
masculine emotional bodies
right like some of us like feel a lot
and that's a feminine emotional body
some of us are kind of dense
emotionally men or women tends to be a
lot of men
and doesn't mean they can't feel but
it's just not they don't have a feminine
emotional body
so but for the sake of simplicity
because i don't want to lose
people here um if we just think about
masculinity and femininity as
transmissions that we could
that happen through our bodies so our
bodies like the radio
antenna or the transmitter and so the
more that your body relaxes
and softens and opens and flows with
love and pleasure
the more the cleaner your transmission
of your feminine
the more my body is solid and clear
and still right the more the
transmission i have is of the masculine
and we don't necessarily recognize that
we have
agency over choosing when and where and
how to use
both of those aspects of ourselves
so a big piece of the work that i do is
to work with couples and to talk about
okay
like if he's moving a lot it's not
probably not very sexy
right you're probably not going like
okay baby all right that's great i'm
glad you can dance
but if he's still and solid and looking
at you very deeply and breathing very
deeply and
rooted that feels like something you
could bring your feminine to
[Music]
yeah or if he was moving and like making
lots of sound that you probably
would not feel comfortable bringing your
your deep
feminine surrender to that if that makes
sense
yeah yeah i can feel the essence of that
the or the feeling of that feeling like
the
steadiness of a man like the steady just
like
you know of reliability the
dependability the strength the
confidence versus um
like a like a zb like a like a kid
almost like
right right or or or it's like he's an
oak we
you know like an oak tree or a rock or
like those
are we don't really take this take the
time to
to take you know to really examine what
that means
what that means is there's a solidity
there's a groundedness
he's somebody in that state is
transmitting
their masculine right whereas
a woman for instance who has
who's feeling really good in her body
like who just feels pleasure in her body
and is moving as pleasure whether it's
in dance or just
walking through the right she's just
feeling the ocean in her hips and the
stars and her i mean poets have been
talking about this
for generations right so the more she's
transmitting that
the more attractive to him she will be
in a moment so am i understanding this
right that
so let's let's fast forward now to being
like in that relationship dynamic
and what if you want to
like what is the grounds to spark
intimacy
like what creates
the table set and ready to go what i'm
hearing and
is that the masculine is steady and calm
and
you know not moving around so much and
the woman is a little bit more
in flow and moving and doing and being
is that correct
well it's often presented that way
through the body
but it's not like a guy has to be rigid
he could move
but he's moving from depth let's call it
right
so that place that we talked about that
interconnected so the essence of
masculine practice as i teach it
right this is how i teach men is to
connect
to to tether to the part of you that is
infinite
and unchanging and then use breath and
use your body
to use breath to ground and open your
body
and from there move from there kiss her
from their you know you know start a
sexual moment
from there you know lead her into the
bedroom
that's that's a a difference that sounds
esoteric but
you can feel it and if i put you in if i
if i did that
in front of a room full of women they
would feel it
and and so that's what we do at
workshops right it becomes so obvious
when you
actually see it you're like okay would
you trust this
more right so would you
for the feminine for your feminine for
you to surrender your heart deeply and
fully to the man you love
you have to trust him not just in life
but moment to moment right so not only
do you have to trust him as he
leads his life in your life but in the
moment
you have to trust him in the moment
there's a
you're looking for that solidity and
you're looking for
and now this can switch it like he could
be in a family he could be totally
flowing
and completely he could be a hot mess
might not know what to do not have
anywhere to go like
baby i i don't know what to do you lead
us tonight
i've been working all weekend i've been
you know i mean like
and it can switch and it can become a
very beautiful moment that way
but by and large most men and women
still fall into these lines of if you're
feminine essence
you want to trust your masculine partner
completely and to do that he has to have
a trustable structure which is his body
and his breath and his awareness
a structure that he's trusting or one
that you know
well both both like you could feel it
right so if
so if we take a moment right because you
said like let's talk about the sexual
moment so let's just take a moment like
you're in the kitchen
and you're making dinner and your
husband walks in
and and
and he walks in he skips
he's skipping walking in because he's
just so happy about something or he's
like really excited about something
chances of that turning into a sexual
moment
probably not great but if he
walks in like we talked about very solid
connected to this core
of himself like literally where you
could like he walks in and you feel
depth it's a you feel it in your nervous
system
and your nervous system can then like oh
like wow he's [ __ ] solid right now
and maybe he steps behind you and he
takes a breath with you
he has now created a structure with his
body his
breath and his awareness for you to
relax
into that now
if in that moment it feels good and you
sigh
you've now brought energy to his
structure like if if he comes behind you
and he takes a deep breath
and he puts his arms on you know like on
either side of you he creates this
structure i'm just giving one
of millions of examples and he breathes
with you and feels good and you sigh and
kind of just
snuggle into him you've given energy to
that moment
he's brought structure you've brought
energy
now you're in a polarized moment and so
the more
energy you bring and the more depth and
structure he brings
the deeper the polarity that could be
created and we have what's known as you
know
really beautiful sex
really kind of juicy spark if you want
to take it out of the center
so there's like a building process in
the beginning
there's like the engagement and then
there's like the reciprocation of
of what's going on meeting at that calm
sort of
emotional body level of like
validation almost right i would call it
response
response like you're responding to his
depth
like he's coming in and he so
the masculine value the masculine value
is that i my consciousness is free
like you can feel the the depth of my
connection to the infinite
truth of life in my body and
in my interest in my aura i guess if you
want to use that word but you can feel
it it's physical
it's it's tangible um
and so you can feel the depth in me and
when you feel that in me
and you're my romantic partner chances
are it's going to feel
good and so if you just let your body
respond
with the energy that's wanting to come
through you
it's the feminine gift so the feminine
gift is the response of energy
to consciousness and depth
right and then it becomes a dance and
like the more energy you bring the more
present he gets the more fierce he gets
the more
you know penetrated with his gaze he
gets the more attention
more his attention just comes like on
you
and then it becomes a cycle that can you
know
elevate forever you know
yeah throughout hours and hours i can
see that
i can see i mean that that is good to me
like for a man out there listening
that's good
instruction of how to start right how to
begin the process and then for what the
woman does after
now let's flip the roles and
what would a woman do to sort of
initiate or start that energetic
exchange process
same rules just let's just call the
moment of blank slate
like the moments of blank slate he could
be watching tv
he could be cooking dinner he could be
sitting outside
and the moment is this blank slate
and so if you come to the moment
and you bring energy that occurs to his
nervous system
as enlivening nourishing
pleasurable energy then you've now
brought the energy to the moment
right and he will likely you know unless
he's just totally distracted he will
likely
take a deep breath he won't even know he
did this
he'll look at you right because you've
now got his
attention and he'll take his awareness
literally his awareness
his consciousness and he'll place it on
you
and so you've you've now sparked that
moment just by breaking out
who knows it's your art right so it
could be you sit next to him and you
start twirling your hair
it could be like what are you reading
right whatever it is it could be
you kind of sachet next to him and let
him feel your hips
it could be it could be anything it
could be just like you purr
at him all of that is energy
and what i see and i mean i'd lead lots
of workshops and what i see
is that men men are craving energy
from the feminine craving craving
craving craving it
it's why they watch porn it's why it's
why
they you know it's why they get
attracted to certain kinds of women
um because they because in this
incredible feminist revolution which
again i'm a huge fan of y'all can't take
over the planet fast enough for me
but there's a certain level of
um
energetic repression that happened
culturally if you if you know what i
mean and
so women are less apt to reveal the
truth of their heart they're less
they're more fearful to reveal their
kind of giddiness or their pleasure or
their you know
some of it's because men have not
treated them well and that's totally
legit
but in a in a romantic relationship that
energy
is the gift it's like it's literally
like food for his heart
this to me is sounds like there's a lot
a lot that has to do with um
it's like the mind heart connection of
saying okay i want to be intimate and
then you go you kind of like
you'd have to really feel it you can't
just go let's have sex and i'm gonna
come over and i'm gonna kiss your neck
and then we're gonna do it's like
almost like that actually just it
doesn't work it's about
how do you how is it sitting like in
your heart space and
in your stump like your whole body is it
you like bringing in that yearning like
that
true feeling and then when you approach
like
the field like as we talk about
beginning that energetic field that
you're
now projecting out hits them and then
you do something
and then it starts going like it almost
feels like there's a first
part that has to happen versus an action
it's more of an embodiment
you know you said the word embodiment at
the beginning but yes right
yeah no you're getting it you're you're
absolutely right and so the first
part of becoming and you know let's call
it an artist or practitioner
in you know in yogic intimacy
let's say or the art of intimacy is that
you have to develop your own practice
so part of your practice if if you came
to me and said hey i want to learn
to deepen in my feminine then you would
come to a woman's workshop and we would
work on
connecting to all of these different
parts of your heart
and then expressing them through the
body so you'd learn
literally to open the channels that take
you from
from the part of you that is sorceress
the part of you that is seductress the
part of you that is queen
the part of you that is innocent the
part of you like the whole the whole
spectrum of your feminine which is
infinite but falling snow you know
full moon like all of it is in a
feminine body right it's all in a
feminine body
and so you would learn as an artist of
love
to to embody those things
and then you could get really good at
turning it on pretty quickly
like i would imagine that when you had
to get into a race car right there was a
lot of preparation and you had to embody
a certain level of
right and it at one point i imagine
you could get there pretty quick if
somebody said
it is a light switch yeah not a pr i go
you go shake hands you take pictures of
people you mingle
hi nice to meet you oh a kid oh and then
you get in the car
and same thing same thing
just you practiced it thousands of times
right
and so this it's the same thing right
the thousands of hours that that to
practice
to to practice all of these various
textures let's call them
of the feminine take some work unless
unless you were raised that way unless
you were raised with sisters or a mother
or in a group of women that
celebrated all of those things and gave
you lots of permission
which a lot of women don't have a lot of
women were shut down for that
um at least in the last few generations
so yeah you work on it and you get
really good at it and then
just like you said you're like okay um
[Music]
we need to be like we need to take care
of business like
it's been a while or he's very stressed
or we need to connect or you can just
feel that
love needs to happen love needs to
happen
and then you can be okay you may not
even
want to per se it might not even be your
thing like you might be like okay i'm
tired
i could really do you have do you have
kids
no okay so for a lot of mothers like
this is the issue like i don't i'm not
sure i want to like i'm [ __ ]
exhausted and and but
love needs to happen for the
relationship
right and so so they've so they've
they turn it on and and and but it's
it's
your the one thing i want to make sure
is super clear it's done
from love it's not done out of
obligation it's done because
of its devotion to love and um
and he has he might do the same thing he
might
he might come home and you he might feel
how exhausted you are from work or
taking care of the kids or anything like
that
and he might be all right love needs to
happen so if he
if he feels that his masculine gift
would be to create structure for love to
happen
so he's creating the structure his
responsibilities create the structure so
he might say
baby here's a glass of wine i drew you a
bath
go take a bath and then meet me in the
bedroom in
an hour he's given you structure
right and you know more often than not
when i say that to women they'll be like
yeah that would actually feel pretty
good actually feel pretty good
right and and so he's given the
structure so now you're in the bath and
you're preparing right and so you're
gonna have to like
find your body like come out of maybe
having to be in your head all day
like oh like oh yeah it actually feels
good to have my body
like it feels good i like my skin i like
my i like the bath i
life feels pleasurable it feels good and
i love
my husband and i love that he is
creating structure and you find like you
said you
you take five minutes to to connect to
the yearning in your heart
and the pleasure in your body and then
your gift to him
would be to bring that to him and
and then the sexual encounter should be
more and more of that on each side
now is this something again i keep going
back and forth but
is there is there can a woman do the
same thing
or is there a conflict in
the masculinity and femininity of
engaging
and bringing about the sort of
want to connect and to be intimate it's
a time for love
can a woman do that too yeah
it just requires a little a little
awareness right so part of what part of
what i'm trying to teach people is that
in the modern world now
everybody's very fluid you know there's
so much fluidity
especially younger people right so 30
and younger
there's much more fluidity in terms of
feminine the masculine energies right so
we have to notice i was talking to a
woman
a woman a couple days ago her husband's
a big hedge fund
owns a big hedge fund but so he worked
he's very much in his masculine all day
long when he comes home
he does not want to be holding space for
anything he's like okay
screw this like how can i just like let
go of all structure
um i sometimes feel that way after
teaching a long weekend
and so my partner she's like
oh there he is he that's a feminine
through
his masculine body it's just exhaustion
and
can't make a decision and doesn't really
know where to go or what to do
she could then say okay baby there's a
bath
i put some epsom salt in the bath for
you take a bath
and then come and join me you know
or or i'll have dinner or you have
dinner whatever food you bring in food
whatever gift of devotion you do
you can take the lead because you
recognize that he's in his feminine
right and so oftentimes what will happen
is it'll just create a space for things
to return back to equilibrium where
he'll be in the bath and he'll kind of
come back into like
okay he'll find his masculine again it's
not going to be there for he's not going
to be in his feminine forever
and vice versa so it's a matter of
recognizing where your partner is and
having a wide enough skill set
to bring what they need for because
again the only rule that i would give
is what serves love you know it's not
like
you always have to be in your feminine
and he always has to be in his masculine
or vice versa
it's every moment is different every
moment is fresh
and if we can develop the skill sets to
bring different
parts of ourself in service of love
things just flow more easily there's
just more love less fighting
you know do you think that um
is there a is there just a widespread
apprehension do you think for
men to go ahead and say like i'm just
tired like you take over
like i just you say that and i'm
thinking would you ever do that
men do that well if they know that they
can
i'd say i'd say you're right
well yeah i think they think that they
have to always keep it together
they can't they can't admit that they're
just [ __ ] spent i'm sorry i don't
know if i can cuss in your podcast but
yeah yeah yeah they're just spent
and uh and they're just done and many of
them
have a hard time especially to a woman
that they love like there's a there's
still this sort of weakness to it
um and and also so what happens is they
try to man
up through their exhaustion and they do
a [ __ ] job of it
and that doesn't feel good to you right
doesn't feel good to him
he he gets more exhausted because he
hasn't fully relaxed
right and and all of this can be avoided
if we just start to understand
more the ebbs and flows of our masculine
feminine
as they move through our bodies so what
does how do we get to that place because
i think this whole subject in general is
like
like when i bring it up it's like oh god
here i go you know like you just don't
ever
it's just like not a topic that you'd
barely bring up in a relationship let
alone
on a public platform and you know having
people gazing into each other's eyes in
a group i mean that's just
i love it i think it's it's something
that's so
needed and you know so
normal and natural um
[Music]
yeah it just i mean what how do you get
to that point where you both
understand each other both you both um
like what's the conversation you have
say like we say we don't talk about
masculine and femininity at all we don't
talk about sexual energy
we don't talk about sex what do we do
okay so give me a little bit more of an
example like a moment like a moment
where you'd want to bring this into
conversation
or you know somebody that might want to
bring it into congress
because i just know everyone's sexual
histories
um well i just mean like what if you
know what if
there's a yearning to improve
improve intimacy right and like
what what do you say when do you say it
and how do you say it where you're like
let's figure let's let's learn how to do
this
better right so it's
very tricky if your partner is masculine
for you to bring that i get this
question
all the time do it shows up where
women will tag their partners on my
instagram posts
like right or or buy this book or that
kind of thing right basically what
they're saying is they're taking the
directional
space they're taking they're using their
masculine they're using direction
to address this issue of wanting more
love and connection because
you as a feminine essence being which
you are
will never have enough love and
connection
there can always be more there it could
always be richer it could always be
deeper it could always
it's [ __ ] beautiful that's the beauty
of the feminine is that
more love is always possible and it's
always there's a part of our hearts that
my heart too that always wants the
masculine
is has the same feeling about freedom
freedom from demand you know what i'm
saying right freedom from demand
freedom is freedom from you know freedom
from demand really
that's that's the big thing right so
you've got these two kind of polarities
that are already at odds a little bit
right and i think we just need to
acknowledge that
because it's it's it's humorous that you
know
god set it up that way but the masculine
is just always craving more freedom
and the feminine is always craving more
um
connection and so if you are a feminine
being and you're having this
impulse for more love then the way to do
it
is to just amplify so
it's not that it's your responsibility
at all
but you're going to be more predisposed
to wanting it than him
if he's masculine he's going to be less
interested in the relating
not you i'm sure he loves you to death
would die for you
right he's but he's going to be less
interested in the relating than you
because your essence is your name you're
a love-driven being
by nature and so
you've got the masculine predilection
for freedom which often shows up as
watching tv
or stoning out in some way zoning out in
some way
games you know it's like zoning out in
some
so you have to be
more your the pleasure and radiance and
sweetness and devotion that comes
through your
body has to be more
magnetic than the pull to
the football game
which in your case might be kind of hard
right given it but yes but
but but but
in general though it's like what's
better than nothingness
and it is the sweetness of devotion and
pleasure
like that's probably the only thing to a
masculine being
that is better than nothingness than
empty freedom than freedom from demand
is the essence of love
purely transmitted through a feminine
body
[Music]
and and so
the the disconnect in a lot of
relationships i see
is that most women will bring that
desire
for more connection through
um more through words
or through requests right or through
right
which occurs to the masculine as
something more to do
oh [ __ ] all right we've got to go to a
workshop now i've got to read that book
now
and it just not and they probably will
because they love you
but it's not their natural it's not the
natural thing that they
that their soul would be yearning for if
you know what i mean
does this all make sense because this is
a this is a big concept
no it it is and i think that what i'm
always trying to
give people and myself is maybe this is
my masculinity it's like
what do i do like right do i do you know
what do we do
what does someone do to say to
address it to want to
make it so comfortable like i mean i'm
thinking of words like vulnerability
and you know how do you get to that like
what is the what is the first thing you
say
and then what do you do well i would
switch it i would switch it so
so because i i get you want to give
people this and it's great so
for the feminine for any women watching
who are feminine identified
if you're wanting to spark more interest
in relationship with your masculine
partner
the way to do it is by is through a way
of being
it's through the way of being like can
you be softer can you be
more filled with pleasure can you be
more
um and and oftentimes just the
amplification of your own juiciness
put it right back to that feeling right
it's back to that feeling yeah yeah
the feeling and the pleasure okay the
secret sauce is
the yearning in your heart yeah for more
connection like that
that never quenched thirst for just
more depth and more connection and the
pleasure in your body of just how good
it
feels to be in a feminine body
he does not have that he does not
have pleasure in his body almost no men
have pleasure in there like like the way
you
you guys do they i mean we our bodies
ache
our bodies are like clunky our bodies
are like
so the the the capacity for
pleasure and softness that the
female i'm gonna say female body has the
male body
has much less of it because for tens of
thousands of years
we had to kill we had to kill to eat we
had to kill to survive we had to
and so our bodies had to be denser
stronger
denser less feeling
less feeling because we had to kill
another human being or kill an animal or
right and this is only 200 years that we
haven't been doing this out of 100
thousand years of
evolution so our bodies still have that
and so your pleasure your energy
is like food for it it becomes like
like uh yeah just nourishment so that is
more interesting than the football game
yeah and it's an art danica right every
woman's got her own
every man too i mean it doesn't matter
you've got your own style of
like like i said he might be watching tv
and you come up and you purr
or you just or you stroke his legs and
you just like
i missed you or whatever and he'll be
like and you just kind of like stay and
you just kind of cuddle
and you let him feel the devotion to
him or to love through your body
and you know like you said that's a
that's a skill set
as important as any professional skill
set
that we develop if not more
right in my opinion so is it safe to say
then that
the the feminine energy is
a little bit more of an action a little
bit more of an embodied feeling and
emotion
and then transmission again all these
words he said right at the beginning
but just like so and then on the other
side of it the masculinity is
is the sit sitting back relaxing the
nothingness
like there's almost maybe less action or
less transmission of the masculine and
more
it's funny you're getting to your
masculine by relaxing you're getting to
your feminine by doing something
well there's a relaxation in anything
again if we went back to
your profession right you were probably
best when you were relaxed
yeah yeah and so same thing right so
but but to get really good now let's say
i was a martial artist let's let's take
if i'm a martial artist and i'm
practicing right
thousands of hours i have to practice
and went by the but the first hour
or first 10 hours or first hundred hours
i'm thinking
block throw block i'm i'm thinking i'm
thinking and i'm getting my body used to
the
action by the time that i'm into
200 300 400 hours of practice
it's just happening naturally and now
i'm not just doing the form but i'm
bringing my art
to the form right and so this is part of
the
film this is why i have a job because
i'm the guy who teaches you
the form and i'm the guy who says okay
like
like let him feel how much love can just
come through this hand
and and i'm telling you a lot of love
can come through that hand
and he'll feel it he'll be like whoa and
he'll he'll like feel you deeper and
you'll be
crying and he'll be feeling those tears
through your fingertips and it's a
it becomes a thing so
what i think most people miss in this
and i'm so glad you asked about it which
is that it all starts with
our personal practices and we should all
have some we should dedicate
some personal practice men and women
should dedicate
some kind of yogic practice or
meditative practice
to our capacities to amplify and animate
our masculine and feminine and
most guys forget that most women get it
fast men take a little bit longer
i think that this is a great way to kind
of bring it all together there's one
like
pending question that i really all like
thought was the most important thing at
just
curiosity that i want to ask but then i
want you to
go into what does that mean like what
are those practices
maybe sharing your own practices um but
what can we do
um to cultivate that within ourselves
and to to get into that practice of
becoming aware of our body and how we
transmit energy
and how we embody the feeling and then
transmit the energy yeah
it would help if i gave one practice for
the men listening and one practice for
the women listening
yeah that would be great but the root
but the question
i'm curious about is
are there just
is there just define roles in a
relationship
like is there just like the man does
this the woman does this or does the
male identifying partner do this and
does the female identifying partner do
this
is there just like a base structure to
the relationship that is just
the way that humans work right
um the the short answer is
no and everybody gets to choose
everybody gets to choose what they want
we're at this party
we're at this amazing point in history
where we don't need each other
to survive anymore you don't need your
husband to survive
you could have children on your own you
could make your own money you could
right
100 200 years ago was not like that so
we're at this point now for the first
time in history it's
really remarkable when we think about it
we don't need each other
to create offspring to work the farm
or to you know for security so you're
not you know
murdered or raped i mean at least in the
western world there's still parts of the
world where this is an issue but
for most of the western world we don't
need each other for the same reasons we
have for
tens of thousands of years so this is
new
really new and um
so that means we get to choose why do i
want to be in a relationship at all
like why do i want to get married or why
would i want to devote my life to this
human being or a human being
and that's a that's a really important
inquiry i think everybody should step
into before they decide
and then why would anybody this is the
one that everybody has problems with
why would somebody want to be in
relationship with me
like why am i where where what is
my value both my value is either a
masculine or feminine
identified human being just as both you
know as a very you know
totally complete whole human being
because everybody should cultivate their
masculine and feminine
and that's wholeness that's that's
really important that they get that
that's wholeness
um and so those two questions
for the first time ever are really
becoming now it we're still at the
beginning of this transition
phase which may last another 100 200
years who knows but we are in a
transition
where for the first time ever we don't
need each other and now we get to choose
so i don't know if that answered your
question but i think it it
hopefully will give people food for
thought yeah
i mean it does i mean i think that it
just it falls back on to
um knowing yourself and communication
yeah yeah emotional awareness yeah i
mean emotional awareness like
am i getting married just because my
parents got married or am i getting
married because i
because my heart is yearning to know
love at this
kind of level and and having that
emotional awareness and like you said a
couple times
being able to connect to it in your body
is a very important practice that that's
needed
in modern society because we're so go go
go go
you know and it's very easy to lose that
i mean
it's kind of this this quarantine thing
has kind of brought people back to it to
some degree i think
lots of babies and divorces through
quarantine you know
it'd be interesting to see the stats
right
yeah yeah exactly but it's true i think
that um
uh the i know for myself
especially based on where i came from
what i did
the job i had and what i was subjected
to
subject it sounds like wrong or what i
had to deal with um
you know i shut down i didn't even know
what it was like to feel my body
like i remember one of the first
practices that i did to learn how to
feel my emotional body was every hour an
alarm went off and i had to
i had to like stop putting my hand on my
heart and go how am i feeling
like what is the emotion i have right
now and i didn't know
like i was like i mean that might
surprise people it might
relate to that but it took a while for
me to understand
you know what that was how to access it
how what what put me into sort of a more
anxious
masculine state and what put me into the
more feminine flow
or feminine i say flow but it doesn't
sound like that's exactly the right word
but a
more feminine calm
sort of space and it was very it's very
interesting and
um so i'm i'm practicing that myself
so that leads to practices you know what
what are those practices
that we each have yeah so i'll just give
one like 10 minute practice
for so if if you have a yoga mat
and you do or you do some kind of
workout in the morning or
every day i would make sure to have a
mat or a sheepskin or something that you
can you know
kind of do some floor work on and
music is always great so let's say you
pick a little playlist three songs two
or three songs
and you move your body in a way only in
the way
so most women still are very linear in
their exercise
right even yoga even like go to a hatha
yoga class it's very linear
right it's all very very rigid very
linear kundalini same thing
i practiced kundalini a long time
so what you do is you go non-linear
for a for 10 minutes where all that
matters
is it feels good to move this part of
your body this way
so i'll make it super simple you take an
inhale you take a 360 degree inhale in
and then move your body on the exhale in
a way that feels really good so maybe
it's your arm maybe it's your leg maybe
your neck
maybe your hips and you just it's a
non-linear movement for about
10 minutes three songs just letting the
music kind of
and feel like oh this feels really oh
this feels good like my arm feels good
and you amplify the feeling of enjoyment
and pleasure
in your own body while you're doing this
so you literally bring your your
awareness to how good it feels to move
your body to have a body
to feel it and then if you want to do a
little bit more advanced work in that
you could connect to that part of your
heart that yearns for the deepest
love and you combine those two things
and so you have this movement of
pleasure
while feeling the emotional experience
of
yearning to be known or seen or
owned or you know what i mean whatever
it is that your heart is wanting
and if you do that ten minutes ten
oftentimes women will find that a lot of
emotions will come out
just the stuff gets stuck in the body
and once you start to move the body in a
non-linear way
things just bubble up so let's just
start there
and you know if we want to go to another
level we can talk again but that's
that's for women
i feel cool do this behind closed doors
yeah it makes sound like literally like
it's again more so make
sound it's it's it's a way to like
celebrate
everything that's just energy and motion
and feeling yeah it's a way to celebrate
that
i did a um i did a little mini 15-minute
class that was
you've heard of kinergy then maybe that
julianne huff created
no i am not but does it sound like this
kind of sounds like that where you're
moving your body
to music and to maybe the elements a
little bit more like connecting with
fire connecting with them
and so i did it and um i
you know did a little post afterwards i
was like it just kind of felt good to
not be so structured
like because i'm i'm extremely
regimented with my workouts it's like
i'm going to do 30 20 10 i'm gonna do
good morning
i mean it's super and it's all it's
weights and you know
um but it was nice to have like no rules
for my body
no rules for the feeling no rules
um for how it just how it flowed
yeah all so so the only thing that
matters is pleasure
you keep moving you don't stop moving
you keep moving but you just move in a
way that feels good
and has no linear sort of thing to it
and it's it's really important just
hormonally
because more rigid our workouts men or
women
the more hormones the more testosterone
we create the more growth hormone we
create
right so this is true for this is true
for men and women
so you want things to be flowy just to
you know just to balance estrogen all
that stuff not none of that's wrong
it's just it's good to have both and
then the second piece it's super easy if
you can't do that on a day
then then do something that feels
pleasurable
like take a bath or if you have a
saltwater
pool like lay in your saltwater pool or
something like that or
or um a wok it's gotta just it just has
to feel pleasurable glass of wine
piece of chocolate whatever feels really
good so it's the pleasure amplification
for men um what i would like
the the practice i would give men
is um it's called an ego eradicator
it's a kundalini practice and i can have
i'll have
jen send you a link if they want to like
just link to it
and it's a it's a it's a breath of fire
so there's a breath of fire through the
navel and there's a very
sort of rigid like a
pose that they take and they ground and
they open up the center column
of their body with breath and it's very
active
and very strenuous but it's three to
five minutes
and it totally changes their brain
chemistry it's very very grounding and
very
enlivening i would start there for men
so if you notice the men's practice had
angular rigidity to it right
and sort of force and the women's
practice had
real flow and pleasure to it and you
know and then you can switch
men i teach men how to do the non-linear
movement too and that works well
wow thank you
thank you so much and i'm just like so
happy to
be able to learn from you and share this
information with other people
um to take subjects that are so
off limits and um
uh i don't know just off limits
for just a comfort zone and just make
them comfortable
yeah it's comfortable um because not if
it's more comfortable
in the public arena it will hopefully
become more private more in the private
as well
um with vulnerability involved and right
and um at the end of the day
ultimately it's hopefully going to
create more love more connection
right that would be my hope is that this
is all just about like
more love yeah yeah
thank you so much yeah you're welcome
danica thank you for having me
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button